please let me have access to my money
this is not right and again this is not
fair wendy williams is speaking out
against her former financial advisor and
wells fargo who she claims is keeping
her from her millions the talk show host
took to instagram on tuesday to let her
supporters know what's really going on
after her bank wells fargo alleged she
is an incapacitated person who needs a
guardianship and can't access her money
57 year old captioned the video quote
i'm tired of everyone speaking as if
they're me in this scenario it's time i
let all of my loving supporters know
what's really been going on with wendy
we've got a lot to talk about lori
schiller and wells fargo
have
this
guardianship
petition
about
keeping me away from my money
this is not right
and you know this is not fair speaking
of that guardianship petition and this
guy named bernie young
in the video wendy brought up her former
manager bernie young who she fired
earlier this year according to reports
young recently filed to be wendy's legal
guardian and wendy alleges he did it
with her money i know for a fact
that bernie young
used my
american express
card to hire
an attorney
to file a petition
against
me
that was done with my american express
card
bernie young
you're no good and this is not fair in
the almost four minute clip wendy's
frustration is very clear this is not
fair this is not fair in a previous
statement from wells fargo a rep for the
bank told et we deny any allegations of
improper actions with respect to miss
williams accounts and are fully
participating in a court process to
reach a resolution that is in her best
interest
the financial well-being of our clients
is at the heart of everything we do last
month wendy's attorney released a
statement firing back at wells fargo
strenuously denying claims wendy is
struggling with her mental health and
her lawyers went to court in an effort
to help her regain access to her money
in personal and business accounts at
wells fargo et has been following these
developments since lawyers for the bank
and williams filed legal documents
laying out their case the tv host
lawyers also filed for a temporary
restraining order against the bank which
a judge has yet to rule on well you know
when people want control of their
account they say anything including
something crazy like that about me last
week in a pre-recorded phone interview
wendy williams shared her frustration
about not having access to her financial
accounts on good morning america they
saying that i need somebody to handle my
account
and i don't want that
i want
all my money i want to see all my money
that i've worked hard for my entire life
my entire life when it comes to wendy's
battle with wells fargo et previously
spoke with attorney miesha a hurrian who
does not rep either party they had some
concerns over her ability to make
financial decisions
and they froze all her assets so she
cannot do the simplest things like
pay her bills they really need evidence
that she is a unsound mind